welcome everybody to this debate I see
it standing room only so what are we
talking about well does the distinction
between the progressive left and the
conservative right remain the central
issue of our time or perhaps there's
something more interesting and more
original that we can find to replace it
that's what we're going to talk about
today and we have a fantastic panel for
you Chantal mu foo is a world-renowned
political theorist David good heart who
was the founder and editor of Prospect
and Rory Stewart reluctantly an ex
Conservative MP you will have all seen
his amazing pitch to become leader of
that party so is it time to move on to
something else our left and right the
antiquated legacy of an area that is no
longer relevant or are there perhaps
alternatives that will be better
descriptions of our current politics and
which might help us improve and
transform political debate so I'm gonna
start with shut up
we need to keep the left-right divide
because this is the divide of the
frontier which is the most conducive to
a vibrant democracy I want to propose
the frontier between left and right
conceived in actual logic or principle
you know as a question of values so
according to the view which are I
defended of course it's an dissociative
view the question for a democratic
politics is not to try to arrive to a
consensus without exclusion but what I
have caught in my wagon agonistic
struggle among adversaries who know that
they are never coming to be able to
agree but who respect the point of view
of their opponent and accept you know to
the fight with democratic procedure and
I speak of an agonistic debate between
people who want a society in which you
know equality and social justice are
going to be the main driving force and I
think this is for me what the leftist
another one which is the right in which
you know basically they accept a lot of
inequalities thank you
Rory
many of us intuitively implicitly feel
that there is a lacking center in
politics and that there is an increasing
divisive and polarized societies there
are two responses to this one of them is
that this is almost an inevitable
feature of the nature of modern
discourse partly fueled by social media
this phone in my pocket and the things
that it enables encourages the creation
of a public that comes together very
quickly against something that a line
runs from the Arab Spring through to
brexit and part of that line is the
general story that there is to quote my
friend David who's just accused me
living in a bubble that there is these
people living above being a right-wing
populist people living in a bubble the
question then is how inevitable is this
is there something about the modern
world something about this machine which
means that any attempt to create a
center ground is doomed and in fact
actually the professor suggested that it
is in the very nature of democratic
politics that an attempt to define a
center ground and consensus is
anti-democratic her implication and her
agonistic vision is that actually a
truly liberal democracy involves
standoffs between one group and another
I would argue that there is a way of
being a trumpian anti-trump that there
is a way of using this machine to
advocate not for the positions of the
right or the left that there is a way of
using this to connect to the local and
the more things are embedded in the
local the more plausible it is that
through practical work through action
you can discover the virtue of
moderation right the virtue of avoiding
the extremes
Heraclitus since we're talking about
philosophy is very interesting the idea
of harmony and what Heraclitus points
out is that harmony comes not by losing
the opposites but by suspending the
power of the opposites what gives it its
force is that it operates in the realm
of
reality thank you David
yes well I mean what is the center
ground is always a pretty central and
contested part of politics and I think
we have shifted in the last particularly
the last 20 years or so 25 years from
politics is primarily socio-economic to
one that is at least partly
socio-cultural that the socio-economic
is being partly eclipsed by the
socio-cultural
I think that's a good thing people
aren't suddenly feeling and thinking
things they didn't feel 20 or 30 years
ago it's just that these things either
didn't need to be expressed or weren't
expressed so I think what's been
happening recently is not a crisis at
democracy its democracy working we have
a kind of disequilibrium at the moment
and we haven't yet found a new
equilibrium I think we probably will
over time left-left be right identities
have become weaker obviously in Italy
and half the voting population now
identified primarily with their brexit
position lis will remain and only nine
or ten percent still identify primarily
with with a party political
identification but it's a it is a very
complicated story because I think we're
seeing a lot of convergence actually on
left V right issues you know I mean to
put it very crudely the middle class has
become less right-wing and the working
class has become less left-wing in the
last 20 or 30 years and there's actually
a very big consensus around a huge
number of issues I mean if we do
eventually resolve brexit I think though
that we will see that there's a huge
consensus that's emerged sort of in in
the undergrowth in the last three years
over things like essentially socializing
adult social care building a whole lot
more public housing investing a hell of
a lot more in in Fe colleges rather than
rather than sending everybody to
university but if that does happen that
would be partly because of a response of
the political class to the brexit vote
and a feeling that the socio-cultural
issues you know the so-called left
behind people had not been included
sufficiently in the Congress
so we've got convergence on left and
right but divergence on the
socio-cultural issues it is easier for
the right to move left on economics than
it is for the left to move right on
culture and that gives the center-right
a really big inbuilt advantage I think
and I hope that Rory will be part of the
conservative team that takes advantage
of it though I do remember sorry I do
remember David Blunkett when he first
became home secretary saying to me
Marianne you won't believe her
right-wing I am so there has there is a
bit of a tradition on the left actually
of being quite socially conservative so
let's let's now talk about whether this
distinction between left and right is of
the past and and whether it's no longer
relevant contemporary politics so Rory
David has pretty much said that the
old-fashioned left and right divide has
least partly dissipated and has been
replaced by what you might call either
anywhere in somewhere but a lot of
people talk about the open/close divide
people who are open on social issues
immigration gay marriage that sort of
thing and people who are socially
conservative do you think post brexit
assuming there ever is a post brexit and
we stop labeling ourselves leave and
remain do you think that might replace
it well the the certainly a lot of
evidence for David's view um I actually
might my political betters against him
but to give a credit this you can
certainly do an analysis of the British
voting public and their views on brexit
where you can divide people between open
and closed I don't recognize it in
myself and I don't recognize that in my
own voters and Cumbria you know I am
somebody who is in many ways a
conservative because I'm romantic and
traditional about the Queen about the
British army about our history about our
tradition I love small sheep farmers I'm
a conservative right I mean I that's
where I come from I'm obsessed with
history but at the same time I am
absolutely appalled by the push for a No
Deal brexit I'm very relaxed in about
issues which really rile up many people
in the brexit party and I believe that
my tradition which is broadly speaking a
tradition of one nation conservatism or
on the labor side I suppose as roughly
associated with new labor is a perfectly
viable way of articulating a way of
being British and it has a certain
genius in it and I think the genius is
that actually we tend as a nation
historically to resolve our conflicts
through compromise that the the
religious wars of the 16th century the
fight between Puritans and Catholics
were resolved through a fudge called the
Church of England that the civil war
between Parliament's and Crown was
resolved by a five court a
constitutional monarchy and that the
theorists have open and closed would
have tried to suggest that that was
impossible they would have tried to
suggest a constitutional monarchy was
the worst of all worlds
you know why on earth would you want
this as a Republican this is offensive
as hereditary principle as a monarchist
this this monarchy has no power there's
no point having it anyway for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the institutes of Arts in ideas
her III TV
you